president Trump delivered a powerful
speech at the National Prayer Breakfast
in Washington this morning he emphasized
our country's dependence on God in the
courage of our fellow citizens we see
the power of God's love and work in
ourselves and the power of God's will to
answer all of our prayers when Americans
are able to live by their convictions to
speak openly of their faith and to teach
their children what is right our
families thrive a communities flourish
and our nation can achieve anything at
all to the surprise of many the
president a man not known for his faith
before the election has become the most
powerful religious voice in the public
arena to react we join from North
Carolina by evangelical leader Franklin
Graham it's so great to see you Franklin
I thought the president today was I
thought it was mesmerizing and I I'm the
Donald Trump is the guy who's holding
the torch for God and Christianity and
judeo-christian culture it's it's
stunning it is stunning and I don't in
my lifetime we've never had a president
like this and he's not afraid to speak
out about his faith but this was the the
66th Prayer Breakfast and he started my
father encouraged going back to
President Eisenhower and others worked
on this at the very beginning and every
president since Eisenhower has come to
this breakfast and it is a bipartisan
breakfast of put on by Republicans and
Democrats and they work together and
these are men and women of faith who
come together in a bipartisan way to put
on this breakfast and it shows you that
Washington can function and we need more
Christians in Washington we need more
could you imagine if the majority of the
House and Senate were were god-fearing
men and women that they could argue
their points but at the end of the day
they would come together and
work for the good of the all-american
people we need men and women in
Washington who believe in God who
believe in His Son Jesus Christ who took
our sins to the cross who died for our
sins who got raised to life we need more
men and women like this and last year I
went across this country to every State
Capitol asking people to pray for this
country and encouraging Christians to
run and I did tell them what party to
run for they could be Democrats they
could be Republicans but we need
Christians at every level of government
and when Christians come together this
is what you see at the prayer breakfast
they come together and they work
together there was a great thing Laura I
was glad to be there at one at one point
the president talked about how a year
earlier he had asked for prayers
for I believe was a little girl who is
very very ill and he said he was you
know he was overwhelmed I heard from
others he had been overwhelmed by the
response the prayer that had come in for
her and he reported that you know she
was doing much better that was just a
small small moment but I know I
personally I felt the power of prayer
and very difficult times and the left
doesn't understand this Franklin because
they say well look he's had been married
all these times and lookie you know he
can have a foul mouth he said these
things in the past how can this flawed
man be this evangelical and and in
Catholic a leader in a way I mean how
does that happen how does God use people
like that and your response would be
well you know you know Donald Trump is
not a perfect person I'm certainly I'm
not a perfect person and I would hate
for somebody to hold me up as being the
the greatest example of the Christian
faith or the Christian life I've got
many failures in my life and so does
Donald Trump but that doesn't stop me
from believing in God and believing in
His Son Jesus Christ and Donald Trump
believes in God and he believes in God's
Son Jesus Christ and I appreciate the
fact that he doesn't run away from his
faith and he's willing to stand up in
front of the whole world and let the
world know where he stands and he
appreciates people praying for we need
to pray you know we're commanded to pray
for all those in turn or Atal or all of
them whether when Donald Lee won the
presidency he became my president and
your
president and we need God orders us to
pray for him Franklin Graham it's so
great to see you thank you so much for
joining us